tengo algunos ejemplos de preguntas de
lacan academy sobre medidas de arco y
como siempre los invito a que hagan una
pausa después de ver cada pregunta para
que traten de resolver los problemas por
su propia cuenta antes de que yo los
haga ahora bien aquí tenemos nuestra
primera pregunta y dice cuál es la
medida del arco ace vamos a fijarnos en
el arco ace y en grados por supuesto que
se encuentra sobre el círculo con centro
en p y que se muestra abajo
así que fijémonos en el arco hace aquí
está el punto a aquí está el punto ce y
digamos como sólo hay dos letras en este
arco en realidad nos estamos refiriendo
al arco menor verdad de hecho hay dos
posibles arcos que conectan aa yace
podríamos irnos hacia la izquierda y
conectarlos de esta forma pero en
realidad vamos a fijarnos en el arco que
se encuentra del lado derecho verdad es
ligeramente más pequeño que el que se
encuentra del lado izquierdo así que
como solo nos estamos refiriendo a dos
puntos de este arco esto se refiere al
arco menor verdad entonces ahora nos
preguntamos cuál es la medida de este
arco que ya hemos marcado y recordemos
que la medida del arco será igual a la
medida del ángulo central que define
dicho arco verdad entonces en este caso
el ángulo central es
el ángulo cp muy bien aquí tenemos el
ángulo
muy bien sería este mismo ángulo y ahora
lo único que nos queda es calcular la
medida de este ángulo verdad entonces
podemos ver que se compone de esta parte
que son 70 grados y esta otra parte que
son 104 grados entonces si nos
preguntamos cuánto es 70 más 104 podemos
ver que esto es simplemente 174 grados
verdad y esta es la medida de largo del
arco en grados muy bien vamos con otro
ejercicio vamos con este ejercicio de
aquí dice en la figura de abajo el
segmento ade vamos a marcar el segmento
ade tenemos este segmento a d
el segmento ade es este que tenemos aquí
voy a remarcar lo en nuestra figura éste
es el segmento ade y también el segmento
c y vamos a marcar el segmento c
el segmento
está el segmento c estos dos segmentos
son diámetros del círculo con centro en
p muy bien la pregunta es cuál es la
medida del arco ave en grados entonces
nos preguntan la medida del arco ave y
hay que darlo en grados entonces vamos a
ver cuál es como solo nos están dando
dos letras en realidad nos referimos al
arco menor y ese simplemente es este
arco que estamos marcando aquí verdad
por ejemplo si quisiéramos referirnos al
arco mayor verdad entonces tendríamos
que referirnos a él como el arco a b o
el arco a debe o el arco a c b pero como
sólo tiene dos letras en realidad está
refiriéndose sólo a dos puntos entonces
nos estamos refiriendo al arco menor
verdad entonces en realidad sólo
necesitamos calcular la medida de este
ángulo central verdad vamos a marcar
cuál es el ángulo central que hay que
calcular en realidad necesitamos
calcular la medida de este ángulo
central cierto es más de hecho lo voy a
hacer con el mismo color sería este
ángulo central pues es el que define a
dicho ángulo cierto entonces cómo
podríamos calcular lo bueno
notemos que este ángulo que tenemos aquí
lo va a marcar este ángulo que tenemos
aquí voy a ponerlo así para que no se
tape este ángulo de 93 grados es opuesto
por el vértice a todo este ángulo verdad
a todo este ángulo y nosotros ya sabemos
de otros vídeos de geometría que los
ángulos opuestos por el vértice tienen
exactamente la misma medida así que este
que tenemos de este lado es de 93 grados
verdad entonces en realidad este ángulo
de 93 grados se compone del ángulo que
queremos calcular
este pequeño ángulo de 38 grados
entonces 93 será este ángulo desconocido
más 38 entonces si queremos calcular
este que no conocemos sería 93 grados le
quitamos los 38 de aquí le quitamos 38
grados y eso nos debe dar la medida de
este ángulo central verdad y cuánto es
93 grados menos 38 grados pues esto
simplemente es digamos y si le quitamos
a ver si le quitáramos 40 tendríamos 53
pero luego hay que agregarle 2 entonces
esos serían 55 grados muy bien entonces
55 grados es la medida del arco ave y
por supuesto está dado en grados vamos
con otro ejercicio vamos con un último
ejercicio dice en la figura de abajo ave
es un diámetro del círculo con centro
entonces ave es un diámetro vamos a
marcarlo aquí está el diámetro ave muy
bien y nos preguntan cuál es la medida
del arco abc en grados y ahora
recordemos nos están dando un arco y
tiene tres letras eso se refiere a estos
tres puntos verdad entonces en realidad
se refiere al arco mayor se refiere a
este arco mayor que estoy marcando
justamente en azul se está refiriendo a
todo todo este arco todo este arco que
es el más grande verdad y recordemos
otra vez que la medida del arco será la
misma que la del ángulo central que lo
define verdad entonces dado que éste
dado que en realidad ahora nos referimos
al arco mayor verdad estará definido por
todo este ángulo central y nosotros
sabemos que ave es un diámetro verdad
entonces dado que es un diámetro
tenemos aquí todo un ángulo de 180
grados verdad y luego tenemos que sumar
este pequeño ángulo de 69 grados
entonces esto simplemente se puede
calcular como 180 grados más 69 grados y
entonces podemos ver que la respuesta de
estos serían 180 más 60 serían 240 y
luego sumamos 9 entonces esto es 249
grados